[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
or as I prefer to think of it Jerry's
Anna and John it's a comedy podcast
about death where two brothers only one
of whom is present to answer your
questions provide you with dubious
advice and bring you all the week's news
from both Mars and AFC Wimbledon my
brother Hank is where's Hank he's on
tour right now he's in a second week of
door wait no aren't I also on tour no
you get dropped you get drawn oh right
that's right I'm only on the first week
of the absolutely remarkable thing tour
and now I guess the second week is
happening so hopefully Hank is having
fun on the road with lots of people who
aren't me yeah I hope so
hey did you bring a dad joke I did bring
a dad actually it's my favorite joke of
all time are some really great caliber
of you okay bring it what did the cheese
say when it looked in the mirror I don't
know halloumi I mean it's a it's a dad
joke well you've got some good news for
us I do I have some great news
rosianna as you know over the weekend as
we're recording this not as it's being
uploaded you and I had the opportunity
to see Taylor Swift in concert it was so
fun that was the best it was just
magical it was an incredible performance
we got to meet Taylor Swift she's so
nice she's just like the most friendly
warm person and I feel very gushy when I
talk about her and I kind of obviously
telling the story over and over again to
my friends and stuff as they asked me
about the weekend and every time I hear
myself talk about how I do sound like
I'm a child
but it's that level of warmth yeah she
also said hey I heard your brother has a
book coming out so Hank Taylor Swift
knows about an absolutely remarkable
thing so anyway we are at the Taylor
Swift Show and someone in the audience
reminded me that the last time Taylor
Swift came to town and made a big deal
about how the weather in Indiana became
like magically perfect all at once and
again the weather has been magically
perfect several days in a row pure
sunshine no clouds it's been beautiful
and I'm visiting from London where it's
really cold right now so coming out to
here I'm really grateful to Taylor Swift
for bringing her
beautiful weather so the good news is
that wherever Taylor Swift goes sunshine
follows I think that's pretty solid all
right you wanna you wanna you and I ask
the first question
let's answer some questions from our
listeners the first one comes from
Thomas who says dear John and Hank I
have friends who I would say excessively
treasure their books I personally like
to see some damage on my books because
it makes that book mine when I look at a
book I enjoyed and can see the time I
walked into a corner of a desk with it
it feels personal but my friends don't
take their books out and keep them in
protective covers is this a thing you do
I'm starting to feel like I don't
treasure my things enough Wallis and
Thomas do do you preserve your books and
take the dust covers off and put them in
special places no in fact I just spilled
a drink on part of the book I was
reading but don't you also only own like
50 books at any one time even though
you're the best read person I know
I do only keep 70 books there at the
moment yeah I try and keep 50 and then
like 20 I'm currently reading they kind
of go in and out but yeah they will
trashed the whole completely like ripped
and torn and I live with someone who
does preserve all of her books very
carefully and she looks at me with
horror yeah I think there's a lot of
good ways to read books and I'm not
opposed to people destroying their books
not least because it might necessitate
the purchase of a second copy but I do I
I dog your pages and all underline stuff
if it's a book that I know I want to
keep for a long time but I do preserve
my better books I have a first edition
of Infinite Jest that I read right when
it came out and I did this like I made
this present for my college girlfriend
that involved me cutting up a bunch of
pieces of paper and like writing reasons
I loved her on the pieces that doesn't
matter the point is that I instead I
didn't have scissors so I used like a
box cutter to cut up the pieces of paper
and I cut into this like mint first
edition copy of Infinite Jest which
today is worth like thousands of dollars
and my copy is worth like 25 bucks but
it has that memory for you of that
special moment I'd rather have the money
I think that for me it kind of makes
books into
objects when you preserve them like that
rather than things that live with you
and go around with you in your life and
you know I won't treasure that book any
less for it having a bend or a tear in
it but it does make it less of a
pristine object and I guess for some
people it's about making them last you
know like yeah if my free I go my
flatmates are no she's very mad at me
when I break all the spines of my books
cuz she's like well now that books gonna
be ruined and you can only read it so
many times but I just read it in two
parts you can just have so when you like
read a new favorite book and you only
have 50 books in your permanent
collection
do you like look do you have in mind
what the 50th book on the list is that
the book that could go if a new favorite
supplants it and did I write it those
are my two questions I don't have a book
in mind I do find that when I'm in the
middle of the book that I'm really
loving I think I want to keep this book
this will kind of you know this will go
in the permanent collection or whatever
but then by the end of it I just
finished this book the idiot by II lift
batiment I really loved but by the end
of it I was like I think I would more
enjoy sharing this with someone than I
would and if I want to go back and
reread it I have a really great library
nearby so I can borrow it from the
library ya know I think that my hoarding
of books is a complete character flaw
it's not something I like about myself
but it's also not something I could stop
doing you could hold West things all
right Rosie Honor we have another book
related question it comes from Johanna
who writes Dear John and Hank what's so
great about Jane Austen I'm an avid
classic literature reader and I love
Twain Hemingway I'm Rand just kidding
Thank You Johanna Steinbeck etc but I
just can't seem to get ahold of the
so-called genius of Jane Austen her
books seem like courtships of rich
British people am I missing something
big not having any visions Johanna
alright so I think what makes Jane
Austen novel special and extraordinary
and the reason they've hung around so
long is a the quality of the
characterization which i think is
unparalleled in English literature and
be the fact that the books explore
issues of class with such subtlety and
such complexity and really such empathy
and I just don't find that in a lot of
other places especially in 19th century
literature so that for me is what makes
her work special but I also think you
know Pride and Prejudice for instance is
the kind of book that can be read
critically over and over and over again
like every time I go back to that book I
find something new I don't know what do
you think and well I'm really biased
because I'm a huge fan of Jane Austen's
I've like reread her books over never
again my favorite is probably Sense and
Sensibility but when I was younger I
used to say that it was Emma because JK
Rowling said that her favorite was Emma
it was like well I will take that
opinion and it'll be mine but for me the
biggest thing I love about them is that
social commentary especially about what
happens to women when their financial
position is called into question in the
time that Jane Austen published she
didn't have the rights women couldn't
legally sign their own contracts which
is why she published those books
anonymously and she was constantly kind
of pointing out all these different
parts of the female experience I think
and while also doing some really cruel
satire at points of the people in those
societies and sometimes when there are
lots of literature people getting around
discussing them there are arguments
about whether she's up holding all these
Regency values and playing into them
with these kind of rich court ships and
so on or criticizing them and that
tension but not knowing I think is part
of what I really enjoy still yeah you
said that way better than I could have
this next question comes from Laura who
says dear John and Hank I just received
an evite to an event described as
elegantly casual can you decipher what
that means what exactly am I supposed to
wear to an elegantly casual event
elegantly or perhaps casually Laura
brilliant sign of that the dress codes
are the worst the worst they didn't mean
anything that especially doesn't mean
anything like what is elegantly casual
does it just mean like expensive casual
clothing like this is a t-shirt but it
costs $200 so it's elegantly casual
we're going back to the Jane Austen
thing and doing like ball gowns but with
trainers right I mean I understand what
casually elegant is a little bit but I
don't understand what elegantly casual
ways like casually elegant is I'm
thinking like a like a little black
dress simple but
still fancy you know like so if you were
a guy maybe you'd wear like your best
jeans a button-down and a blazer but
definitely no tie
like it takes you 30 minutes to get
ready not three hours right exactly
but I have no flippin idea what
elegantly casual is like are you just
supposed to wear like new sneakers do we
have to have like wings on them or
something right yeah
I you should not go to this event Laura
I mean this is not gonna be a good party
just don't go my trick with dress code
favorites to start with the second word
because I feel like the second word is
the sensual part of the dress code okay
so like business casual or smart casual
casual as a center thing but then the
word before it which unhelpfully here is
elegantly modifies that a little bit so
if it's like smart casual or wear a
casual outfit but with like a blazer on
top of it or something again not quite
sure we'll make it elegant maybe a cape
maybe heels oh yeah maybe so maybe you
just wear like what you'd wear to the
beach but with your best shoes I love it
I'm not I think we've cracked it yeah
Laurie you came to the right place for
fashion advice and you got it
so the next question comes from Leticia
who says help I'm going to a dinner
party in the coming week and the people
there are friends with my friend and
they are known to banter full-on
roasting a person until they're cooked
into their basic components
I'm not witty it takes me a couple
seconds to collect what they have said
and come up with a reply but by then
they assumed they are 40:1 not to
mention how I was born in the house that
spoke two languages and my pronunciation
isn't up to par all my friends say I'm
smart and I'll be fine but among these
people I'm a sheep in wolf's clothing in
need of palm cards and the defibrillator
literature PS were all a bunch of
fifteen-year-old teens but PS is helpful
because prior to that I was imagining
like a dinner party full of professional
comedians who roast each other that you
have to show up to but no these are just
15 year olds you'll be fine you're gonna
blow them away I agree I was I was
imagining an elegantly casual dinner
party you know packed with people and
capers in half
and beachwear but if there's
fifteen-year-old it's okay I'm very
sympathetic to the situation there cuz I
don't I don't feel like I'm a like a
roaster at all I can't come up with that
like quick wit and the idea of like
going to a roast is probably my idea of
hell but I do think that there is
something to when you're in those
friendship groups being the person who
says the kind thing being the person who
isn't cutting I dunno I absolutely agree
like if you're not confident in your
roasting abilities then lean into your
empathy and kindness I have a group of
friends in my neighborhood and whenever
any of the guys turn 40 we have a party
that involves roasts and I mean I
probably have worked as hard on the
roasts that I've written for those
parties as on anything I've ever
published but the people who are most
successful at those events are always
the people who make the difficult choice
to be sincere and who are sweet and kind
and when everyone else is being mean
they're like you know what I like I like
the euro loyal friend because that's the
couple that no one saw coming
exactly right it's actually pretty easy
to write jokes that criticize people and
that make fun of them there's a joke
construction that I like to use you look
like blank and blank had a baby so for
instance my best friend Chris looks like
Vince Vaughn and Vincent D'Onofrio had a
57 year old baby like 20 feet tall a 20
foot tall 57 year old baby it doesn't
work about well just stick with
sincerity I think there's a dinner party
situations can be so tense as most you
never really know what you're getting
into yeah but the thing you have to
remember is that everyone else also
feels a little tense and and nobody is
actually paying attention to you like
this is the central insight that my wife
had when she was in middle school and
that I unfortunately didn't have until I
was like 28 years old all the times that
I worried that people were like oh god
that guy is not as smart as the rest of
us or not as quick
weird or whatever what they were
actually thinking was something about
themselves you know I mean most of the
time most of us are thinking about
ourselves like what they were actually
thinking was man my stomach hurts or I'm
like I wish I could get rid of this
eyelid twitch that I'm sure everybody is
noticing that actually nobody is
noticing so you have to remember that
everybody is also feeling a certain
measure of anxiety as they approach this
extremely exciting dinner party which by
the way just the fact that you're doing
this it means that you're miles ahead of
almost every fifteen-year-old in the
world I agree all right rosianna we have
another question from Kimmy who writes
Dear John and Hank I work at a grocery
store that's open 24 hours a day I
generally work until 11:00 at night and
I like my job but working that late
means that I go to bed late and then I
have to get up really early some days to
go to school I'm in college so it's not
a legal to schedule me that weight after
about 9:30 it gets really slow here and
I start to get tired so I was wondering
is there any way that I could train
myself to sleep standing up like a horse
thanks in advance Kimmy the best thing
about sorting through Hank and Joan
questions at the moment is that Gmail
has updated itself and in Gmail's
horrendous update it has added three
suggested responses to every single one
of your wonderful day Hank and John
quest is that your send again so please
do keep sending them in because gmail is
bringing me a lot of loves and for this
jima has suggested all right actually
can I read you the question and then you
will read me Gmail's responses is there
any way I could train myself to sleep
standing up like a horse of course you
can is there any way I could train
myself to sleep standing up like a horse
yes you can do that is there any way I
can train myself to sleep standing up
like a horse no sorry
Kimmy I regret to inform you that the
answer is indeed no sorry I think it's
something about like paralyzing your
limbs or something that's why we can't
sleep standing up yeah I mean some
people can have moments of sleep when
they're in extreme levels of fatigue
while they're standing up but it's hard
to have long-term sleep when you're
standing up unless you're being held
all sides by some kind of force like in
an extremely small room that's the size
of you which doesn't sound like a
pleasant sleeping experience anyway so
you are probably gonna have to at least
sit down I used to I have a little bit
of expertise in this field actually
because I've slept at a lot of jobs I
used to work at Steak and Shake on the
graveyard shift and what I would do when
the restaurant was empty is I would sit
down at a table in the very back of the
restaurant and I would sit down at like
3 o'clock in the morning and I would put
my head on the table and do you know
what bad things would happen as a result
of me going to sleep kill me none
nothing it was fine nothing bad happened
when somebody came into the restaurant
at 3:45 in the morning they would come
over and tap me on the shoulder and
asked if I could take their order and I
would be like yeah of course no big
whoop I feel like that probably kind of
expecting it truck drivers away for
America like I like quite used to waking
up their service and being like hi yeah
totally I I think that look obviously in
a perfect world you don't sleep on the
job but if you have to find a quiet
place to sit even during your 15-minute
breaks maybe find a quiet place to sit
if you can assuming you get 15-minute
breaks which you're legally supposed to
find a quiet place to sit leaned against
a wall and at least close your eyes give
yourself a little bit of a break because
it is really hard to work standing up
late at night go to bed and find a way
to shut off your brain fast enough to
get enough sleep to wake up to go to
college it's a lot so get that rest
where you can I used to try and get
songs stuck in my head on purpose when I
was kind of between like the 9:00 p.m.
and like 11:30 p.m. shifter at top man
like at the very end of that of that
shift in retail and I would just get a
song stuck in my head and would like
aggressively sing it to myself for those
last few hours and that kind of worked
but then it made me hate those songs
forever yeah the only problem with that
is that sometimes then you dream about
the lyrics or at least I do and it feels
like you've got a song stuck in your
head even while you're sleeping which
can be annoying but to get back to your
question Kimmy I regret to inform you
that it's gonna be tough to sleep
standing up like a horse speaking of
music we've got a question from a media
on a Sandman
Dear John and Hank I listen to a lot of
music especially on my one and a half
hour bus right to school every morning
every time I listen to another one bites
the dust by queen everybody I see
walking out the window is walking in
time people start either on every beat
on every second beat or halfway between
each beat sometimes I find someone who
isn't walking in time but after a few
seconds they change to match it I am
very confused is there something to do
with our heartbeat or does everybody
have an 80's disco playing in their head
another one bites the dust well the
other one rides the bus Amelia
that's a great sign of Amelia it occurs
to me
Rosie Hana that as you and I are
recording this nobody in the world yet
really knows about what a central role
Queen the band plays in Hanks and awful
and absolutely remarkable thing oh you
don't know that either I forgot that you
haven't read the book I'm really excited
yeah so I guess I can talk about this
now it's not really a spoiler because
it's in the first 20 pages fine there is
a very important part of the book that
is contingent upon the Queen song don't
stop me now which I'd never actually
heard I mean I've heard it but it never
meant anything to me until I started
reading the book and now I was into the
song all the time here's my theory
because I've been listening to a lot of
Queen it's not that everyone walks
either on the beat or halfway between
the beat it's that there's the exact
right number of beats to give you that
illusion that's my theory I will say
when I hear that song another one bites
the dust it is one of the most
percussive pop songs I've ever heard and
so I think part of it is maybe that you
feel the beat of it you feel the pulse
of the song a little more than you
usually doing pop songs I don't know
it's an interesting observation though
Amelia related your one and a half hour
bus ride to school
sounds like a very long time every
single day well gives you time to listen
to podcast I guess I love it why do you
get that feeling when I'm listening to
music I look outside and I think Oh
everyone's walking time but then I just
remember that I'm in The Truman Show
the whole world revolves around me right
there right that is the other
possibility that I hadn't considered it
that reminds me that Alice has recently
gotten pretty into music especially the
artists pink oh so Alice's favorite
color and Alice's favorite musician and
one of the things that Alice says
whenever a pink song plays like a song
things like any time a pink song comes
on the radio or any time I play one in
the car
Alice immediately just shouts it's my
soundtrack and it is a wonderful thing
to have a soundtrack to feel like when
you're just walking through your day
there is music that is accompanying you
I was thinking about that because it's a
new experience like pre Walkman you
couldn't have that experience like you
couldn't you couldn't feel like it's my
soundtrack wherever you were walking
around because you either didn't listen
to music or you were forced to listen to
music with other people so you had to
wind up the gramophone and
right yeah it's been or learn to play
the piano or something yeah I have
someone follow you around with the
massive piano another great option let's
choo there I'm I remember the early
stories that I used to write I used to
add in the soundtrack to the book as I
was going and I looked back and found
some of them and it was entirely Britney
Spears like really like 25 Britney
Spears songs per story that was lifted
from the baby-sitters club
yeah wait you wrote baby-sitters club
fan fiction essentially but I was also
just plagiarizing that is something I
did not know about you what we both love
the baby-sitters club then yeah very
much baby sister Club and Sweet Valley
High were like my earliest books that I
read I stole them for my sisters they
were also tremendously important in my
development I may have told you this
before but when I was in college I had a
huge fight with my college girlfriend
and I was like crying and inconsolable
and I read Claudia and the sad goodbye
to make myself feel better it's a
heartbreaking story it is it's a
beautiful story and really listen I
haven't read the babysitter
club books in a long time I think
quality and the side goodbyes might have
been the last one I read but I read like
70 of them at least 10 times apiece and
they so deeply shaped my understanding
of what stories can do and of what
narratives exist for my favorite was
that Island adventure it was one of
those like special ones and they all get
stuck on an island and they have to fend
for themselves for like a weekend or
something I love that I also loved boy
crazy Stacey that was it not a solid
classic I think the island adventure one
might have come out after my time but I
love desert island books and I love
babysitter Club books so maybe it's time
to hold on I'm gonna google it
baby-sitters club babysitters Island
Adventure it's got three three point
eight stars on goodreads which probably
means it's great I find that older but
all my favorite books have three point
something on Goodreads
well most almost every book right or two
point something see all buying options
it's available for a quarter fit pricey
was Claudia your favorite but Claudia
was my favorite but I don't know I am
really really excited to read the
baby-sitters club desert island book
that is right up my alley it mixes my
two favorite genres of literature well
you know what Claudia's elegantly casual
yeah Claudia actually just look on all
the claudia book covers like all the
ones where Claudia is the star and you
will see the definition of elegantly
casual in fact I'm cooking at the
baby-sitters club super special Island
the baby-sitters island adventure right
now and Claudia looks phenomenal she
looks super elegantly casual I don't
know how we got on that topic what are
we talking about Queen but anyway here
we are let's move on here's another
question all right this one comes from
Claire who writes dear brothers Greene
I've recently dived into the world of
tending to bonsai trees I'm extremely
happy and have great fulfillment in
caring for these tiny trees and all the
details required I've done extensive
research on their specialized care and
I've received many recommendations to
join my local bonds
club but I'm hesitant to attend a
meeting first off I'm a college student
and by the looks of their newsletter I
would be the youngest person there by
many decades also I'm afraid that their
expertise will embarrass me there is so
much to learn in this field and I'm just
beginning my tiny accomplishments I get
what you did there I get what you did
there Claire my tiny accomplishments are
pinching leaves successfully whereas
many of them have 20 years of experience
in twenty year old trees how should I
approach this Club meeting should I even
go crystal clear Claire
you should absolutely go yeah you have
to go this is a high-quality learning
experience for one you will learn so
much about tending to bonsai trees but I
also think it's really fun to go into
things that you don't know everything
about and also things that are
intergenerational I think too often now
we kind of hang out with people who are
our age and we don't really have that
many opportunities to meet other people
from our communities and local clubs are
such a great way to do that
I totally agree look there's a tiny
percentage chance that you're gonna go
to this thing and all of the people are
going to be super rude and the group is
going to be extremely insular and you
won't like it and you'll never go again
but the overwhelming majority of the
time what's gonna happen is that these
people who have been hanging out
together for twenty years and who are
all seventy-five years old are gonna be
so flippin psyched to find out that
there is a young person interested in
bonsai trees it is going to make them so
happy they will love hanging out with
you you will learn from them their
wisdom not just about bonsai trees but
about everything will become a part of
your life moving forward I think it's so
I totally agree it's so important to
have intergenerational friendships and
there really aren't that many
opportunities for them outside of work
places so I think it's super important
when I look at my life it's people who
were a generation older than me who
really helped me the most in my not just
in my career but in terms of becoming
the person I became
and I think something I read in your
email is this fear that you have nothing
to offer them that you kind of it's only
their expertise and kind of you this an
expert person but from the sounds of it
I feel like you could improve their
newsletter for one you have skills that
you can bring to the table too and if it
is all people who have done it for 20
years and their trees were all 20 years
old they may have forgot
and how to talk about the new experience
of beginning it and I'm sure they'll
really enjoy and relish having that like
Ally experience of bonsai tending
revisited yeah that's the other thing
I'd say Claire is that there's a pretty
good chance that you are going to find a
novel or a movie out of this story like
it's such a good setup for a novel like
you meet someone to use 40 years older
than you and who is you know like a font
of wisdom and then you die you know at
the end of Act two but then it turns out
that you're stronger than ever just like
the little boats I treat you have learnt
to tend for I mean we already wrote the
movie for you Claire
which reminds me that today's podcast is
brought to you by bonsai trees bonsai
trees so little this podcast is also
brought to you by Jane Austen Jane
Austen with her acerbic wit and acid
directions she'll cut you down today's
podcast is also brought to you by
another one bites the dust by Queen
another one bites the dust
it's your soundtrack whether you like it
or not and finally today's podcast is
also brought to you by Gmail Gmail no
sorry yes that sounds great every time I
read a short email now I assume that
Gmail wrote it and my feelings are hurt
like we've become cyborgs as you know
I've given you this rant already but I'm
worried that we're already cyborgs
roseola the ship has sailed
I'm very frustrated that it keeps
telling me to say yes to things what I'm
trying to say no to them as well like it
often it won't even give me an option it
will give me three guess options yeah
it's like Google also has a hard time
saying no it wants me to put things in
its calendar that's right if you don't
have like a densely scheduled life you
might not need your Google Calendar as
much then they can't say that's to me
and then they're deciding what we do
with our lives what we look at what we
value moving on I'm upset all right all
right this next question comes from
Aidan who writes Dear John and Hank as a
high school senior I am currently in the
process of being swallowed hold by the
college application process as part of
this I have to write a lot of
myself something that I'm not great at
mainly because I really don't want to
come across as obnoxious or
overconfident how do you draw the lines
between not having enough
self-confidence having the right amount
and being a jerk
oh my god I'm learning Aaden I love that
I think it's so hard to apply for
college or university because you really
have to sell yourself you have to go
hard on like here are all the best
things about myself and you have to do
it kind of shamelessly to be honest Yeah
right you have to make the case for
yourself which also involves making the
case that you're not the kind of person
who makes a case for yourself it's so
meta and difficult my wife wrote the
most amazing college essay Sarah was an
amazing student in general but the
college essay that she wrote was just
phenomenal because it was about all of
these things that she had done and all
of these things that she hadn't done and
how she wanted to go to Northwestern so
she could do all of the things that she
hadn't done and so it didn't come across
as overconfident at all it was like I've
done this and this and this and this and
this and I may have gotten great grades
and I may have volunteered at this place
in that place but I haven't yet you know
learned about twentieth-century women
artists doing self-portraits or whatever
it was such a good essay like even today
I couldn't write that good of a college
essay so Aidan just uh steal that idea
from Sarah I know it's a good approach I
can tell you something's not to do don't
make lofty statements about truth which
is what I did a lot of I just kind of I
felt like I had to imitate my idea of
what a university student was like when
I was applying for things like that um
and I also felt like I needed to give
something really personal and kind of
share something really close because
then that's how they would know about
you but you have to remember that the
people reading your essays have never
met you before they don't know about
things that you do in your free time
they don't know about any of the ways
maybe your friends would describe you
and that's another thing I'd say is ask
the people around you how they would
describe you and try and build something
from that but yeah really
do I hope like start to inhabit this
place where you start to believe
actually I am really worthy of getting
into this place and often the things
that you feel like can come across as
obnoxious and overconfident are really
just you giving yourself a really good
chance I would also say though I agree
but I'd add that it's okay if you don't
get in to your dream school and we hear
from so many people who write in to this
podcast who are deaf devastated that
they didn't get into their dream school
disappointed by the college that they're
attending or so overwhelmed with anxiety
about where they're applying and whether
they're gonna get in and what that means
for their future and it is a big deal in
a big moment and I absolutely understand
that but at the same time you don't know
what your future looks like you don't
know really whether it's good news or
bad news that you got into this college
or that college or didn't get into this
college or that college I look back in
my life and I don't think things would
have gone as well for me necessarily as
they have if I'd gone to a school that
was quote unquote better because I went
to the right school for me yeah and I
was so devastated when I got well
actually we knew each other I remember
oh I got rejected from Oxford which was
my like I just spent the last like ten
years like fantasizing about going to
that school when I got the rejection two
days before Christmas and I was so upset
I dyed my hair red I was like I'm just
gonna rebel now and then I stopped at
dyeing my hair red because I felt like
that was kind of enough for me but
actually it was probably the one I'm
like I say it was the best thing that
ever happened to me obviously it sucked
but it was a really good like pivotal
point for me in learning what was
important and also just kind of you know
this really bad thing can happen that
you're dreading but things go on you
know yeah your life goes on but also you
can get a good education at universities
other than Oxford yeah absolutely and in
fact you did okay yeah I for one am
really glad that rosianna didn't get
into Oxford because I suspect if she had
then we wouldn't work together today so
I won the lottery Thanks
okay we have a question here from Katie
who says dear Hank and John or John and
Hank John Amery xiana I was friends with
this girl let's just say her name is
Patricia in most of my childhood years
however we both went to different
secondary schools and inevitably drifted
apart we were both quite popular in
primary school but my popularity has
decreased to a whopping number of one
friend whereas her popularity rate has
increased by a lot
she's beautiful sporty and lovely I'm
the complete opposite out of the blue
Patricia invited me to hang out with her
after three years of not speaking this
is a stressful situation enough but she
invited me to a theme park with her dad
it's going to be me her and her dad I
don't even know her dad
what if he's horrible what if she is
horrible we have literally nothing in
common so what the heck do we talk about
I don't sing the song bra Katie Katie
have you checked to make sure that
you're not inside of a young adult novel
I think we have to consider the
possibility it's just such a good setup
Katie it's even better than Banzai
Claire's setup in terms of the narrative
potential you gotta see this as an
opportunity for a great story whatever
happens you've got a fascinating cast of
characters here and an amazing setting
in the form of an amusement park I think
it's perfect one thing I would say the
only things that I I would say is is the
bad thing about this setup
wellmaybe provides narrative potential
is that there's going to be three of
them at a theme park and most
rollercoasters there's two people
sitting by side-by-side right so you've
got like the dynamic of who's gonna sit
next to whom or maybe it's a way into
meeting a stranger at the theme park
befriending them and having them come
along on your journey - there you go the
love interest the love interest or the
Merlyn figure right yeah Dumbledore
Dumbledore loves 80 miles per hour he
can't help it
oh this is great Katie you've just got
to lean into this experience because
whatever is gonna happen is going to be
fascinating the closest I ever had to
something like this I was a huge nerd in
middle school
and for some reason I had one magical
day ice-skating with the two coolest
girls at my middle school they were so
generous to me and so nice to me they
were never like this before or after but
they were so nice to me that day they
like helped I couldn't ice skate for
crap of course but they held my hands as
we like ice skated around and it wasn't
romantic or anything it was just lovely
it was generous and kind I don't know if
their parents had told them to be nice
to me but it worked
and I honestly that it like was a fire
that burned in my Center all through
middle school and so when things were
bad I would be like well at least there
was that one time at the ice skating
rink and maybe life will go back to that
someday again and it did so maybe it's
gonna be that maybe it's gonna be
terrible but either way it's gonna be a
great story the best thing about a theme
park is there's no shortage of
activities like there's no kind of empty
time really because it's always kind of
like should we go on the next roller
coaster should we go get this strange
plastic food like there's always
something else to do except for the six
hours that you spend in line talking to
each other but that is where you go deep
Katie that's where you say you know
maybe maybe on the inside Patricia
doesn't feel like she's sporty and
lovely and super popular maybe she has
some gnawing insecurities that she needs
to talk to you about maybe her dad hmm
and then just not that interested in
parents maybe he can fetch the buggers
yeah I mean yeah maybe he'll be sort of
like blandly supportive like the parents
and all of my novels but a little bit
overly anxious that's my prediction oh
not that yeah or dead anyway you can
have a great time or not yeah you know
it'll be fun it'll be fun um you do need
you do need to go though because it's a
great opportunity I don't know what kind
of opportunity yet please keep us
informed about this especially if you
discover that you are inside of a why a
novel because that's a
I want to write we are open to buying
life rights from any and all of you it's
so true it's a dollar a piece by buying
we mean suing that's right we already
own Claire's life rights we call we
claimed them all right Rosie oh no we
have a question from another Katie who
writes Dear John and Hank this year all
I want from my birthday is a cordless
vacuum cleaner I've been there Katie
like I want it so much I have dreams
about it anyway my problem is that I
live with a roommate who is not willing
to invest in one and normally I don't
mind sharing my things but I'm already
sharing more than I'm comfortable with
her and as she's extremely clumsy she
has also already broken several of my
belongings am I being too petty if I
don't want to share the hoover of my
dreams with her if she's not willing to
go halfsies on it should she still be
allowed to use it and if not how do I
tell her that she can't use my cordless
vacuum cleaner I feel silly but this is
really bugging me
please help hopefully soon cleaning
cordless Lee Katie oh you've got to have
a conversation with her and address it
up front yeah I think this is a
communication moment Katie it sounds
like some resentment has maybe built up
a little bit I suspect that this isn't
really about the vacuum cleaner it seems
like it's about like a bunch of other
things that include the vacuum cleaner
my feeling with vacuum cleaners and
correct me if I'm wrong about this
Rosanna is that if somebody wants to use
a vacuum cleaner in my house they are
welcome to nice if it's a Dyson this is
what I feel like she's implying I feel
like katie is buying a Dyson cordless
vacuum cleaner which caused hundreds of
pounds yeah I don't know is that like
five bucks I guess what I mean is this
if someone would like to clean a mess in
my home they are welcome to and I think
it is a little weird if you have a
vacuum cleaner in a two bedroom
apartment and you're like this vacuum
cleaner only vacuums this half of the
apartment because you wouldn't go
halfsies on the vacuum cleaner like it's
probably technically within your rights
but I don't think it's gonna lead to
like a healthier roommate relationship
but it will lead to you having an
operating vacuum Cleveland I guess yeah
then they won't break your vacuum
cleaner that's the upside the downside
is that like people are gonna come over
to your apartment and be like hey so
what's up with the weird line in the rug
and you'll be like oh no I
I only clean this F of the apartment and
then I stare from my half at the
apartment at my flatmate because they
broke my cookie jar 14 years ago and I
haven't gotten over it yet
you seem to be saying like that's
unreasonable I think that's perfectly
healthy I mean I guess to be fair it's
been a long time since I was in a non
spousal roommate situation but when I
was I'll tell you I was so happy if
anybody wanted to vacuum anything go
right ahead sir oh man
the common rooms in my apartment were
always very well-kept but my particular
room was filthy not just messy but
actively dirty like nine-month-old
remnants of Big Macs dirty Oh God yeah
so maybe about that person to borrow
your vacuum cleaner yeah I think that
there is a there is a way through this
you sit down with your roommate and you
say okay I understand you not wanting to
go halfsies well you don't really
understand but like let's pretend you
understand on this vacuum cleaner let's
set some ground rules for how we're
going to use this vacuum cleaner here
are the ground rules I mean is that too
much that's like if you sat me down and
you were like we need to set out some
ground rules for the vacuum cleaner use
I would be like shut the front door
vacuum you're welcome
that would be my response on my first
day living with Sanne we went around the
kitchen and pointed out all the things
that each other was allowed to use and
not use Wow so we're all intense I
remember like three or four years after
I moved out of my apartment with Shannon
she called me and she said you know that
a white computer and I was like yeah or
that white computer and she said it's
mine now
[Laughter]
so different people yeah yeah you know
figure it out just communicate that's
the key okay Rosie on it's time for the
news from Mars and AFC Wimbledon I'll go
first
AFC Wimbledon played Scunthorpe I you
know it never gets old saying the word
Scunthorpe what is it like living in a
country that has place names like
Scunthorpe well you passed them on the
train and you wave at the ladies
you're where are you from and they say
Scunthorpe have you ever been discomfort
I haven't actually
well it seems lovely based on the
stadium ASU olden lost 3-2 to a
scoreline that based on my viewing of
the game rather flatters Wimbledon the
two goals that we scored were pretty
good
quest ce o-- Pius scored one liam
Trotter scored one nice to see Liam
Trotter get on the score sheet but oh
god we gave up three really horrendous
frustrating goals
so now AFC Wimbledon are down to 16th in
Ligue 1 8 points after eight games a
negative five goal differential it looks
like even though we have mostly
different players from last year at the
moment at least we have a similar team
the important thing is to stay up that's
all that really matters I just want to I
just want to stay up get into the new
stadium 16th is a completely acceptable
finish but uh God it would be nice to
win a couple games just feels better
feels so much better when we win yeah it
really does the one thing that I will
say is that Sunderland despite having a
parachute payment from being in the
Premier League two years ago that is
something like 35 times larger than AFC
Wimbledon's entire playing budget are
only in fourth
so you'd be surprised well as you know I
went to see the West Ham like my two
teams West Ham and AFC one was in play
each other in the carabao Cup quality
quality cup and for me it was you know a
whole 45 minutes plus thinking o FC one
wasn't gonna win this despite the fact
that their budget is miniscule compared
to West Ham's
ya know I also thought in the first half
Wimbledon looked like the better team in
the end playing with 10 men against the
11 of Premier League for the season
anyway
West Ham wha with a little too much but
yeah I mean that's the thing Wimbledon
at several points this season have
looked really really class including
pretty good against Sunderland so it's
just can we put some results together we
shall see what's the news from Mars well
the news from Mars is more like an
article about Mars there was a really
great piece in the Atlantic that came
out over the weekend by Geoff minal
whose name I'm sure I'm pronouncing
perfectly all about how Mars will be
policed and how murders and things will
be solved and created on Mars which
reminded me that a lot about the Mars
discussion is actually this like
philosophical thought experiment about
how we can create a optimum Society when
we're bringing it all of our biases to
Mars but some of it was also about how
DNA will leave will have a shorter life
span or Mars or a different life span on
Mars
how splatter patterns will be different
how depending on whether the body is
exposed to winds and whether it will be
the bones will be bleached or not I went
quite deep here but who's reading about
it it's very positive but I feel like
this is a podcast about death so you
guys can handle it um there was a
further discussion there is a researcher
who has created this optimum space
prison which you might think is actually
quite dark but part of what he was doing
is making it possible for oxygen supply
to continue regardless of how the guards
were feeling towards the prisoners so
that there are basic life rights and
responsibilities and so on and a lot of
this comes back to where nations start
and begin who has authority over which
parts of Mars and all sorts of different
discussions that I hadn't even thought
about all collapsed into one little
article so that's how Mars will be
policed and that's on the Atlantic
I will send a link to the patreon as
well that is really interesting and it
reminds me of this great PBS Digital
Show America from scratch have you seen
it yeah it's really good it
engines for instance if we were forming
the United States tomorrow
would we have States and if so with the
lines for the states be where they are
of course not
of course North Dakota and South Dakota
would not be two separate states but it
imagines all of that stuff if we were
starting from scratch with the United
States what would it look like and I
think that's such an interesting
intellectual exercise because it
obviously we have to work with the
traditions that we've inherited but at
the same time we have to innovate and I
for one would love to read a
murder-mystery set on Mars
well there's apparently a ma strategy of
some sort oh yeah that's Hanks favorite
book oh is it do they have do they have
murder mysteries and I just having to
read them okay well we'll investigate
that further by talking to Hank
rosianna thank you so much for parting
with me it's been a real pleasure thank
you it's been so much fun and thanks to
everybody for listening as well if you
want to email us you can do so at Hank
and John at gmail.com you can also find
rosianna on Twitter occasionally at what
is it these days
where's jana rojas and i'm also
occasionally at john green where else
can we find you on the internet well i
have a podcast with my friend let's
could make out with him it is a
friendship bromance and kissing podcasts
but we often just go off on tangents
about i don't know prince harry most
recently very very fun i also have a
youtube channel at youtube.com slash
rosianna where again i know dearie otic
lee but I wouldn't say regularly yeah
that's the case more and more with more
and more parts of the social internet
for me these days but that's a different
podcast called delete this with Hank and
Katherine I heartily recommend make out
with me by the way especially if you
like advice podcasts with lots of
tangents and if you're listening to this
one at this point in the podcast you do
so check that out thanks again for
listening this podcast is produced by
rosianna halse rojas and also by
Sheridan Gibson it's edited by the
brilliant Nicholas Jenkins our head of
community and communications is Victoria
Bonjour now you can find us at
patreon.com slash dear Hank and John the
music that you're listening to right now
and at the beginning of the podcast is
by the great gunnarolla and as they say
in our hometown
Dave Righetti Austin
[Music]